this sensation hit me almost immediately
after solo but definitely after
spider-man into the spider verse and now
lego movie - I wanna see the Lord in
Milverton was so low
I'm just we're all curious right it had
to have been better I've realized that
there's nothing to do with Lego so let's
review the lego movie
[Music]
like a movie to the second part so lego
movie 2 is the sequel to the wildly
successful lego movie when is there was
an invasion in the lego world now pretty
much they're worlds like Mad Max so now
they have to save existence itself or at
least their existence their lego worlds
existence it involves this other
dimension where everyone's way too nice
to Stepford Wives brainwash to green
eyes and they made a new character it
sounds like Chris Pratt doing it Jack
Burton impersonation so we come for the
last we come for the heart and then we
have a new adventure I enjoyed this
movie I thought it was cute I thought it
was nice I didn't enjoy it as much as
the first lego movie maybe because the
end of the lego movie just totally flips
your head upside down oh wow wow yeah
this movie plays off of that concept a
lot I like that they do I mean what else
can you do except embraces like alright
we let them know how it is now so let's
just live it up let's not hide it there
was a feeling I got in this movie that I
didn't get with the first lego movie and
that is this movie is made for families
and kids I mean obviously the first lego
movie is made for families and kids but
I felt more so I feel like this was more
geared towards young people that are in
the course of the past five years I've
just gotten older I don't know I don't
know which one both can we say both
whereas I walked out of the first lego
movie going yeah that's pretty kick-ass
it was awesome that was unexpectedly
good I liked how this movie going that
was cute we just want to say about
enjoyable kids movies that are made for
people way younger than me but this
movie did keep with the lego movie Lego
Batman didn't see that other one from
what I know the leg of movies being like
it kept with that humor that pop culture
entertainment movie world humor I always
dig that because I get that I know that
it's I know that now this movie does
have a really good lesson about the
family dynamic because these movies are
about family and I felt for the most
part it worked in here however they kind
of go in a direction to make a point
like a social point in order for that to
land the movie isn't as smooth as it
could have been whether or not that's
worth it to you that's up to you so in
the end for the most part I enjoyed lego
movie - it doesn't stand out like lego
movie one day there were a couple of
plot points and plot devices I love the
concept of a lot it wasn't executed as
smoothly as it could have been executed
even one moment where something's
happening and you could go about it a
few different ways a dramatic note would
have helped a lot instead they went the
funny route so there's that I've been
granted by the end I was I really dug
what they were doing with the family
dynamic well I had a bit of the man tier
going mmm in that rugged manly way but
that's for that but the movie has a
whole that was like
but that other so okay I guess the
family message is sweet just makes the
movie feel a little anticlimactic but if
you're looking for something to take the
kids to take the kids to like a movie -
they will enjoy it every kid in the
audience did I think you'll enjoy it -
I'll say the lego movie - the second
part is a good time no alcohol required
kind of funny they do make a point here
where she's talking and she's like oh
yeah he is our hero she's putting -
Chris Pratt's character and the new
unknown character is like you mean you
did all the work and the hapless male
took all the credit kind of reminded me
of that scene in wreck-it Ralph - the
lego movie - this movie with a
progressive plot is scoffing at and
deconstructing movies with older less
progressive plots those archaic movies
from so long ago like its predecessor
the lego movie from five short years ago
oh this is kind of crazy when you think
about life moves pretty fast
I saw the lego movie - the second part
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]